- [Instructor] Before we dive deep
into our study of government and politics,
it's worth asking a fundamental question.
And that's whether we
even need government,
or why do we need government?
And I encourage you to pause this video
and think about this.
Do you think we need government, and why?
Or do you think we don't
need government, and why?
Okay, now let's start to reason
through this a little bit
and start to think about the benefits
or the pitfalls of a government.
So let's say that we are in
a world without a government.
And this is me right over here.
And at first, it sounds pretty good.
I have unlimited rights here.
There's no one infringing on my right.
I can say what I want.
I have the freest possible speech.
There are no laws that I could break.
I have the freest possible religion.
I have no government
telling me what to practice
or what I can't practice.
I have,
I can own what I want.
I have property.
I can go anywhere,
so I have movement.
And I also have some freedoms
that those of us who live in a government
don't typically have.
So I would have the freedom to tax
others or to take from others,
take property.
If I'm stronger than them,
or if I'm just sneakier,
I go in the middle night,
I can just take their property from them.
I could just settle on their land.
I could have the freedom to punish others
or imprison others if I don't like 'em.
It doesn't even have to be for a reason.
This is a freedom that
most of us don't have
in the world that we live in today.
But without a government,
I would have this freedom,
this freedom to go and
take stuff from others
and to do physical harm or
imprison them or enslave them.
Now, this might sound good
to you as an individual,
but remember everyone in
this government-less society
would have these same,
would have these same freedoms.
And I especially like the
ability to have my own property
and to have my own freedom of movement.
But what if this person right over here
doesn't like me to have
freedom of movement?
And so they say they're
going to invoke, look,
I can punish or imprison you
because I don't like you.
And so they're going to infringe
on my freedom of movement
by imprisoning me,
or maybe I might do it to someone else.
And so even though you
have all of these freedoms,
because everyone else does,
especially these latter few,
they might be able to take
some of these from you,
including your freedom to live,
your health, your happiness.
And this is well-described
in political philosophy.
In particular, you have a gentleman
by the name of Thomas Hobbes,
who's considered one of the
fathers of political philosophy.
And this is what he had to say
about this state of nature.
"As long as men live
without a common power
"to keep them all in awe,
"they are in the condition known as war,
"and it is a war of every
man against every man.
"In war, the two chief virtues
"are force and fraud."
I can do something by physical force,
or I could trick you,
or I could sneak around you
and take something from you,
or imprison you.
"A further fact about the state of war
"of every man against every man,
"in it there is no such
thing as ownership,
"no legal control, no distinction
between mine and thine,"
between mine and yours.
"Rather, anything that
a man can get is his
"for as long as he can keep it.
"In such a condition, every
man has a right to everything,
"even to someone else's body.
"As long as this continues, therefore,
"that is, as long as every man continues
"to have this natural right to everything,
"no man, however strong
or clever he may be,
"can be sure of living out the time
"that nature ordinarily
allows men to live."
This was written in Leviathan,
which was published in 1651.
So he's framing the same thing.
If everyone has a right to everything,
well, they can infringe on other people,
including their life, their
health, their happiness,
their freedom to movement.
Now some of you might
be skeptical of this.
You might say, look, humans
are fundamentally good.
If you give 'em that freedom,
they have a conscience.
They're not going to try
to do this to other people.
But some of you might be
able to cite times in society
where there's more of an anarchy
where actually people might devolve.
And even if one or two or three,
or even if a majority of
the people have a conscience
and aren't willing to imprison others
and punish people arbitrarily,
if even a few people are not willing
to respect other people's rights,
everything might devolve.
And it's worth talking about
the historical context here
because this was near the
end of the English Civil War,
where there was chaos,
where people were asking these questions.
Well, what type of
government should we have?
And when there isn't a strong government,
all of this chaos is really
all about person versus person.
It wasn't this degree of chaos
that Hobbes is writing about,
this kind of natural
state without government,
but this was a context where
there was a lot of bloodshed,
a lot of war, and a lot of chaos.
Now, Hobbes had a solution,
and this is actually why the
book was called Leviathan.
He was an advocate of a very
strong central government.
This keeps people in awe alludes
to what he's thinking of.
Leviathan comes from the Old
Testament or the Hebrew Bible.
It's the name of a sea monster.
But Hobbes thinks that a
government should be a Leviathan
to keep everyone in check.
He wrote,
"When a man thinks that peace
and self-defense require it,
"he should be willing,
when others are too,
"to lay down his right to everything,
"and should be contented
"with as much liberty against other men
"as he would allow other
men against himself."
Now, this idea that he's talking about,
this is today referred to as a
social contract.
And this term social contract
is first formally used by Rousseau,
another Enlightenment author,
about a hundred years later,
talking about this willingness
to give up some rights
in order to protect the ones
that you really, really,
really want to have.
And you would be giving up those rights
to some form of a government.
That is the social
contract between the people
that are governed and the
government that governs them.
So going back to that previous example
where every person was out for themselves,
what the social contract is saying is,
well, look, certain of these
rights, I really want to keep,
my freedom of speech,
my freedom of property,
my freedom to move around,
my freedom to have my life,
my health, my happiness.
In order to protect those freedoms,
maybe I'm willing to give
some of my other freedoms over
to a central authority,
as long as everyone is
willing to give these up.
And this central authority
that we give it up to
is a government.
And the government, because it has this,
it uses these rights in order
to protect the other rights,
the ones that I really want to keep.
So the government enforces
these other rights,
and that's the social contract.
I give away these rights
in order to protect the ones
that I really, really care about.
And that makes sense,
but it still leaves a
very, very big question.
What form should this government take?
I'm willing to engage
in this social contract,
but how does this government govern?
How are the leaders selected?
What are the constraints
on that government?
And that will be our focus
as we study government and politics.